Okay, so with your Atelier Robin machine, this is the icon you can see my cursor there.
This is the icon that you're going to click on to open up the program.
When the program opens up, you may see frequencies are not installed.
You may want to download them.
This is just a reminder you can update your frequencies.
If you're connected to the internet, by all means, you can hit OK.
I'm not right now, so I'm going to hit cancel.
And I will open up my program.
You can also update your frequencies.
We change any frequencies of the standard frequency set by going to file and then down to
update frequencies right there.
If you click on that, you'll update your frequencies again.
It just takes a couple of minutes.
But of course, you have to be connected to the internet, so I'm not connected to the internet,
so I won't do that.
But that's another way to update your frequencies.
If you want to connect, what's different with the Atelier Robin is that you can connect
to the Wi-Fi.
And it's even suggested that if you can get a Wi-Fi connection, if you have a good home
internet, then you can connect to the Wi-Fi.
That's actually better than connecting via the USB cable.
You might have less issues.
If you want to connect to the Wi-Fi, you go up here to this screen up here, the tools and
the Wi-Fi setup.
So this is that when you open up your program, you'll see file, edit, tools, help.
Under the file, you'll just go to, you'll see, do, open.
These are the same commands that are over here on top of the screen up here when any program
is opened.
But make sure you don't mess up a program that I created for you by saving it, by changing
it and saving it or saving it as that could mess up the program, so be careful of that.
But that's where you'd get to the update frequencies.
That's where you'd get to the properties, if you're somehow your USB is not connected.
You could click on that and see, is my generator connected?
I want to connect via the USB, so I could click on that and hit OK.
If my generator wasn't, couldn't find the generator for sub-reason.
I could go to properties and go up here, and it's searching for an IP address right now.
This is not connected to the internet, so it won't find anything.
So I am connected right now via the serial port or the USB port.
So I will click on that and connect and set, yes.
And then up here again, where I was at file, you go to edit, you're not really doing anything
out of there.
The tools, this would be the Wi-Fi setup.
You'd set up the Wi-Fi at the beginning of time, and you may have to do it multiple times
if your whole Wi-Fi changes.
It's IP address on a regular basis.
Some whole Wi-Fi's don't do that, some whole Wi-Fi's do do that.
And you can also hit find generators to find your generator.
The help, there's also a user guide, and this tells you what current software that you're
running with this.
This is the user guide if you want to get really dirty and look at your user, because I can't
get to my user guide because I'm, oh yes, I am, I guess I am connected to the internet.
So it does pull up the user guide.
You don't have to be connected to the internet for that.
But that's how you would do it.
But now, once you go back to open home, and you might want to run a program.
Now your program will be up here in alphabetical order, AA, your name, and you'll run your
weekly sets.
But this is an example.
Let's just go to bacteria science program, and then you can hit run, and then it sends
these frequencies to the machine.
Now you don't hear anything.
It is running, but you don't hear anything, now this is because it's a very high frequency.
It's typically in the lower frequencies that you hear a loud beeping noise.
And remember, that's coming from the generator itself, and it's just, it is what it is.
You can't change that.
You got a very powerful generator pushing out these frequencies to penetrate your body.
We suggest you put the generator under your bed, if you have to, even put a light pillow
over it, just make sure you check it on a regular basis so that it's not getting hot.
Now, once you're in the program, you can hit stop.
Now, if you hit stop, now you hear that little beep by it stopped, then you hit run again.
It's going to start over at the beginning.
If you don't want it to start over at the beginning, you're going to, let's say you're
ready to show a program.
You're just going to get up and go to the bathroom, but you don't want to miss anything.
You can hit pause, and then come back from the bathroom and sit down again and hit
continue, and you're running from that spot.
If you hit stop, and then you hit run again, you'll start over from the beginning.
Now, we suggest you don't hit hold and pause.
That's if you want to get dirty on this, and you want to hold on a frequency, or if you
want to skip a specific frequency in your frequency set here.
But typically you're going to be hitting stop and run, that's the only thing you're going
to hit.
And typically, even when you run your overnight programs, when you hit run, you will just
typically just let it run out, run its course, even if you've got up and left for the day.
You just leave it run out and time out.
Of course, you'd have to open up your computer again and make sure it's connected, and then
you can hit stop if you want, or you could simply turn off the generator.
Some simple concepts there.
Again, here's your file folder, where you would update frequencies or go to properties if
you can't somehow connect to your generator, or if you needed to go to tools to set up your
Wi-Fi, or find your generator, get device info firmware update.
You don't recommend you do that unless you talk to us, but just kind of play with this
and get your way around it, you can't really hurt anything.
So get a feel for how your generator works.